drôle de bête le blob a pris possession
de la classe de thomas payant professeur
d'arts plastiques au collège debussy à
saint germain en laye les élèves créent
le temps d'une heure un stop motion via
le fait qu'on utilise la pâte à modeler
moi-je sahara chic c'est trop bien et
enfin juste film et l'évolution une
idée originale et en fait j'ai hâte de
voir le résultat
plus haut que nous qui travaille chez la
même chose que nous en fait celui qui
est le plus haut c'est thomas pesquet le
spationaute français étudie 4 blob lors
de la mission alpha dans l' iss et lève
ton blog est une expérience proposée par
le cnes un projet que le corps
professoral de l'établissement saint
germanois souhaité développer dans
différentes matières c'est aussi un
moyen de les faire manipuler des outils
numériques avec un créative
et là c'est aussi une occasion ça va
être une occasion en tout cas de
découvrir l'animation vidéo et comment
fonctionne le cinéma ou les principes du
cinéma avec un certain nombre d'image
par seconde en troisième on étudie
beaucoup la question de l'oeuvre
l'espace et le spectateur ça fait partie
du programme
et je pense que à travers ce projet là
en tout cas il va être question aussi
beaucoup de voir ce qu'on peut produire
en terme d'image est ce qu'on peut voir
aussi en termes de spectateurs au
collège debussy les adolescents vont
élever des blobs et travailler sur cette
thématique tout au long de l'année les
professeurs nous donne rendez vous en
novembre cette fois ci pour un cours de
svt